Okay. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich webs. Oh my, let's talk.
Yeah, do it. Oh, I'm Molly Webster.
Yeah. Just graduated and party,
join the party. And uh, today
we have a, I don't know,
we have a birth story. We're calling this
birth story because that's what it is.
We're going to tell you about babies who
were very recently born and who one day
will turn to their parents and say to
them, tell me how I got here. Like what's,
what's, what's my story? What's my story?
And the parents in this case will say,
well that's complicated. That's, yeah.
This is one where the kids will hear
what we're, you're about to hear.
And they'll go, really,
it's a collaboration with a team of
reporters in Israel called Israel story.
They, a group of folks who do sort of
long form reporting and storytelling.
They'd been doing it in Hebrew for three
years and they are in the middle of
their first English language season
right now, which we're going to be in.
Exactly. And uh, this is a two producers
that we worked with in particular,
Maya Kosovar. And you'll high Mattel
and a, this story begins with Maya.
Okay.
It was party. We were all dancing
Israeli music in the middle of Jaffa.
Mr Birthday. They were at her
apartment and it's guy tall.
How was dancing with his partner? These
are friends of yours. Yeah. Tallies.
Kind of mega star in the deaf community
in Israel because he translates the news
in the TV to deaf people to sign language.
Oh well so he's like the little
guy in the corner of the TV. Yeah.
And his partner,
a man Amir or a meal with an r is a
psychologist that works specially with
children that are autistic. Huh.
Anyway, they're at the party.
So we were dancing all
together and then a pal was,
oh my God,
maybe it's going to be the list party
that I'm in because I'm going to be a
parent and not only a parent,
I'm going to be a father for three.
And then we were like,
oh my God, three babies,
how's that going to happen?
And it turns out how that
was going to happen is a
crazy story involving a four
countries, women, two guys.
And three babies as we mentioned.
And planes, jet planes, two of them,
hundreds of thousands
of the, at least four.
Yes. So yes, all that. But we
should, we should go back a bit
to the beginning. The first
speaking of that I started in [inaudible]
is, Eh, is his ability to be a father.
This is a mirror.
Really? Yeah. How so?
Because a, it was a good man, you
know, he was very, uh, gentle,
a little bit and really an adults, eh,
to be in the family. I don't
know how to describe it though.
Thanks.
Did you see that like on first meeting
or was this like four months in
my career is established work with the
district people and to take notice for
every sign though of communication and a,
and to understand that the
people and to analyze them.
So it was really immediate. They said,
let's say after two or
three times you say,
okay, Eh, I want children.
So yeah. Are you interesting?
I wrote a manifesto about my
future. What I want to do,
what I want to do in my career.
It's kind of my vision and I gave it to
him and I said this and this is what I
want. A sign at the bottom, please. Yeah,
that was a contract. It's like this is
what I want. If you want to join me, Eh,
so let's do it. So let's do it and
tell. What was your reaction to the,
to the manifesto? I like it.
It's look like someone who want a future.
It's your own parents.
Have any either of your parents have
any views about that saying don't do or
that's weird. Yeah.
Suffice to say their
families did not approve,
especially when it came to
the idea of them having kids.
Now how to have those kids. That
is a question. Basically there,
there are two options. If you're
a gay couple and you want to have,
there used to be three
options. That's you Chi.
My towel from Israel story here is
how he and Maya laid it out for us.
Option number one, which is
now not as much of an option.
You could adopt a kid from
a third world country,
but he says over the last few years
what happened is that those third world
countries figured out who was adopting
their babies and one by one they banned
it for gay couples. The second
option, which is becoming very,
very popular in Israel is
sort of the new family.
That's what it's called in Hebrew at least
sort of getting together with another
woman who wants to be a mother but
doesn't have a father and then they do a
joint parenthood. They all
live in the same house? No,
the mother lives separately and it's
kind of like divorced parents that get
along really well.
They sign a contract before the process
and everything is like in the contract
telling them your said that
early on they tried this route,
eh? [inaudible] from one of his
friend to do the coparenting,
but then I spoke with
Talend, ask him, listen,
it's very important for me to have
a baby of my own and with my sperm.
And I said to [inaudible] I want to try,
but I don't care if in the end we
have only one baby in your sperm,
so it will be my baby the same.
I think I was more stubborn
about it. [inaudible]
Amir couldn't really explain
why it was so important to him,
just that it was important to him.
But reflecting on it later, my, uh,
from Israel's story, put it this way,
it's very Jewish and Israeli. I mean,
if you're not in the Israeli mainstream,
if you are gay or if you are different
and you'll have your own baby,
it's like a, of being
part of the game, you know,
whatever the reasons. A Amir and tall,
talked it over and then they went back
to this woman tells Fran who had offered
to do the coparenting
and we asked her if she can obligate
to us to bring two children,
one of of thous berms and one of my own.
In the end she said no. And at
this point a year had gone by.
Well.
So then we've decided that maybe the
best option will be option three is,
is surrogacy
[inaudible]
meeting. Of course, if you're a
gay man that you take your sperm,
take some eggs from a woman,
put your sperm and those eggs
into the womb of a second woman
who carries the baby to term.
But surrogacy is illegal in Israel
only for gay couples. Yeah. In Israel,
if you're a Hetero couple, you can
use an Israeli woman as a surrogate.
But if you're gay you can't.
So there's a big problem.
But that problem also creates a
big demand, as you can imagine,
are quite a lot of gay couples in Israel.
And so a company's spraying up basically
offering international brokering of
sperm eggs and uh, ovaries,
babies outsourcing
[inaudible]
Harlem. And they don't meet the Moose.
You can see this play out every year at
these conferences in Israel conferences
where they'd get prospective
parents together.
We are here for our first time in Tel
Aviv, so it's this big room of people,
several hundred people, Pretty
Michelle Gay men. Pardon me,
for not being able to speak
Hebrew very well or at all Shalom.
Basically what happened to
these conferences is that
surrogacy agencies will get
up and basically sell their products.
We now offer surrogacy in
Mexico, Thailand, Anima,
the United States, India. Anybody
been to fort worth? Very nice place.
You can go see a basketball
game and go see a baseball game.
These agencies will find women in all
of these places who will serve as the
surrogate for your child and depending
on which country you choose and whether
or not you provide the donor eggs or
they do, or a million other factors,
the costs will vary.
We offer very, uh, competitive
prices. For example,
$36,000 complete start
to finish in Mexico.
38,000 in Thailand,
anywhere from 65,000 to 85,000, 150,000.
It could be that much.
That's excluding the donor of course.
But we have a good selection of donors
including uh, Jewish donors as well.
Yeah. The have session with the
lawyers. You have session with families,
you have sessions with doctors
telling them your went to two of these
conferences,
success of years and coming back from
the second one we take a calculator and
you start how we can make
it raising money. Money,
money. Yeah.
They figure if they go with a company
that does surrogacy in the u s it's
probably going to cost $150,000
or is that lawyers and lawyers,
the hospital, the spare
delivery, uh, the egg donor, uh,
there is a lot of people
that we need to pay
and he says, keep in mind
when you pay that money,
you are not guaranteed a baby.
You'll buy a process. Yeah.
We don't buy a baby.
One of our friends did this kind of
process and they spend five times and they
still didn't succeed five times. Yeah.
They figured with that kind of risk do
we get in the u s was just too expensive
and so they started looking at surrogacy
agencies which operate in India,
in Nepal because over there you can do
the same thing and it will cost you about
$60,000 so it's almost half price,
almost a half price. Yeah. Now
one of the tricky things according to
get high is that in 2013 India basically
outlawed surrogacy for
gay couples. I mean you,
if you're a straight couple
you can do surrogacy in India,
but not if you're gay.
Also in a part by the way in Nepal also
outlawed surrogacy effectively that
Kevin had said, if you are a Nepali
woman, you cannot be a surrogate period,
but there's sort of a loophole.
Indian women are allowed to
be surrogates in the pilot.
Just Nepali women aren't allowed
to be surrogates in Nepal.
So what ends up happening is
it's really strange situation.
It looks like it puzzle.
These agents in northern India will
find Indian woman move them across the
border into Nepal.
I'll take them all the way to Kathmandu
where the surrogacy agencies have set up
shelter houses and work with
local hospitals and clinics.
My assessed for talent, Amir, the
decision to do it this way was not easy.
They had like different opinions that
had the bigger issue with the more rural
concept of this process. Amelia was like,
this is the thing that we need to do.
I want to be a father. But Pal was,
it was very hard for him.
I thought the, if it's, it's
a moral to do things like that
[inaudible]
to use and other woman to give
me a presence like that and,
and I know she will never
will see this baby anymore.
Is it a moral, because you're essentially
like just using a woman's body or
eh, yeah. Yeah. You can say
he felt like he's using other
people bad luck for his own good.
Yeah. She has no choice. She's
not doing it out of freedom.
She's just doing it for the money and
maybe it's not morally okay that will use
this weakness telling me or went
back and forth on this for months.
And eventually the argument
that won the day was this did,
if they're going to do it, they're going
to do it with this agency called Lotus,
which to their understanding
paid the surrogate's $12,000.
I mean, the surrogates were
actually paid in Indian rupees,
but that would be the
dollar equivalent. $12,000.
Now for a rural woman in India,
that is a massive sum of money. They
figured this won't just help her survive,
it will change her life.
She'll be changing their life and
they'll be changing hers. Maybe this,
um, kind of like comfort.
Yeah. They get money.
They can change their
life. They can buy a house,
they can send the her
children to school, Eh,
to learn in the university.
When I felt and understand it's,
would it be a life
changer? And the, it's not
exploiting it. It's
bloating are so I agree.
Mm.
At the start of the whole process,
one of the main issue was to peak the
egg donor and like who are these women?
Like where do they come from?
Ukraine. They're from the Ukraine.
They're all Ukrainian. What is that?
That is not a country I expected to
be thrown into the mix of countries.
The reason the eggs are from
eastern Europe are generally
because was a no white
because they're white, so it's like
cheap white eggs. She pointed eggs.
That's quite a phrase.
So you have like a website and you see
a lot of pictures of women and then you
need to choose the most Eh, like JD? Yeah.
Jewish online dating service. Yeah.
I think it was the most straighty ish
act that I did in a very long time.
Oh, straightest nice. You're
picking out a lady's? Yeah. Yeah.
How did you decide which criteria
you wanted an a donor mom. Oh,
the first one was high. You
wanted someone tall? Yeah. Why?
Why was height your first
one? Because it's smart.
Easy to lose it. Yeah. When
your height. Yeah. Okay.
Then eyes. She has the speak eyes.
They showed my a picture light brown
here and she has this nice nose.
If was, you know, very strange.
It was very uncomfortable to
choose for me. It was very uh, eh.
[inaudible], Eh, genetical
uh, improving. Oh.
Jenica Janay eugenics. Huh?
Now since telling them your head, each
one at a baby with their own sperm,
they told Lotus we would
like to rent two wombs,
one of each sperm, and to try to
use like two surrogate mothers.
Lotus said, fine.
That's going to run you about
50 $60,000 each pregnancy.
Again, no guarantees,
so telling the mirror they'd give
lotus their sperm and little cups.
Lotus raises the sperm, sends it to a
hospital. In Nepal, the Ukrainian woman,
the egg donor is flown to Nepal.
Her eggs are harvested somewhere
along the way to north Indian.
Women are moved across the
border into Nepal. Finally,
the doctors at that Nepali
hospital take the Israeli sperm,
injected into the Ukrainian eggs,
create some embryos and the implant.
Those embryos in the wounds of the
Indian surrogates for countries.
One baby, a few months go by.
They get the news that both surrogates
are pregnant. The process worked.
One is pregnant with three babies and
all their scent, sonograms, pictures
of the surrogate's, pregnant bellies.
I all the time,
look on the picture of her
all the ultrasound pictures
all the time looking on
my cell phone. In the picture it tells,
says there wasn't really much he could
do cause for three or four or five
months, not much happened until
[inaudible] six months, six o'clock
in the six o'clock in the morning.
Donna from Lotto call us and the Amir
was answered the phone and they hear him
say, okay, they're okay.
I wake up and say what? Because
it was too early, too early. How early?
About eight to eight weeks. A head. Wow.
The surrogate who was carrying twins
had given birth. I was crying a lot.
This is the surrogate caring tiles
baby, which turned out to be two babies.
Yeah, and were you on the plane?
The same day is getting the color and
day after we fly from Tel Aviv to instant
bull and from Instanbul
tool couple months.
It was very crazy today.
Then gala, this is one of tiles friends
who was also in Nepal for surrogacy.
Took me to the hospital and
well
I was shocked
because Gilly was so tiny.
Gilly was 3.8 pounds. His brother,
you have all 4.8 pounds and
yeah, I was very scared to touch him.
He says he expected the twins
sustain the hospital for a month.
But the nurses were like,
nope, going home tomorrow.
I thought they don't ever enough time
to think because I understand tomorrow I
need to take them home and to be alone
and I never take care of in the babies.
So I said, I said to the nurses,
teach me out to feed them.
After three days I took them home.
So where was the surrogate during
these days? Was she at the hospital?
I think she was in the hospital. Yeah,
because she had the [inaudible] surgery.
I was ask if she's okay
and if she needs something.
They said you cannot see her until she
signed all the papers and then you can
see her. The papers
hadn't been signed. Yeah,
because we need that.
She's giving up all her
maternal lay rights and if
she doesn't want to sign this
paper
we can lose the baby.
The last on this game,
crazily complicated. But
basically they needed Israel,
India and Nepal to all recognize that
they were the uncontested parents and as
all legal rights and hanging in the air.
We've been terrified was
the recent case in Thailand,
which is all over the
news where the surrogate,
which right after the baby was born
changed her mind lake and his husband and
believed this surrogate decided to try
and keep the baby because she found out
they were gay.
We had a little bit of an anxiety,
let's say they will going to know that
their baby's going to grow in the house
with through that
any case tall is in Nepal with the
twins. Amir is back in Tel Aviv.
A couple of weeks go by and then
eh called me and said the [inaudible].
The second surrogate had given
birth one baby and they after
you
[inaudible] one from symbol tool Linda
and then it was very, very,
very nice that we went, eh,
only asked with the babies. We'll let
no parents, no friends, no phone phones,
no wall to build the first Eh, Eh,
blocks of our relationship
with the babies.
Some [inaudible]
and for the next month they
lived in an apartment in Nepal,
just them and their three babies.
[inaudible] learning
to be dads [inaudible]
being a goose and waiting for the
paperwork to be done. What's the bands?
So
now the paperwork incidentally is a beast
because after the surrogate sign away,
their rights,
the babies have no nationality and
then they're suddenly illegally in the
country. So then the guys have to
take a DNA test, send it to Israel,
get it verified, then they've got
to get a passport for the babies.
Then several sets of visas need to be
gotten and all of that means multiple
trips to these Railey embassy.
And it was on one of those trips
that they learned something.
It was really weird because we went over
there with our eight kids to get the
passport and over there there was
another surrogate from a different agency
in Indian woman and standing next to
her was in Israeli woman who happened to
speak Hindi.
And we just go, you know,
out of curiosity, we eh,
asked her to ask the surrogate in Hindu,
eh, how much she's, Eh,
she's getting for the whole process. Yeah.
But the surrogate was very shy. Yes.
Not Very delighted to speak about the
money, which made them even more curious.
So they persisted and then Eh,
we discovered she gets only
3000 to use stole or something like that.
Yes.
$3,000 for the whole pregnancy.
Amir was like, wait a second
in the agreement,
$12,500 supposed to go to the surrogate.
That was at least his understanding.
Now this was a different woman from a
different agency and this was just one
woman's account. But
still in your narrative,
you've described that you thought that
the reason that this was okay to do the
surrogacy is because you
are using the phrase users.
This will make a change in the life of
the woman that was a life changing sum of
money.
So Maya says they walked away from that
meeting wondering if they should do
something in Israel, you know, call
the agency at the very least. Say, hey,
we heard some rumors, I'm sure they're
not true, but what do you think?
We started to ask question, but
then literally the next day,
[inaudible] ran the scenes of death and
destruction from Nepal today after a
powerful earthquake that
started outside Putman
[inaudible] death toll is now over 5,800,
nearly 14,000
[inaudible] officials
say it is the most destructive earthquake
to hit Nepal in more than 80 years.
The death toll would ultimately rise to
somewhere between seven and 10 years.
A thousand Maya says
she was in New York, uh,
in a meeting and she gets
this voicemail from Tal
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and he was shouting
in earthquake. Just happened here.
We saved the babies and we got down
to the street where half naked,
we don't know what to do. And
he's crying over there and then
[inaudible]
it suddenly stopped the,
he lost the connection.
Mm. It was, uh, like 12 hours
with no connection to them.
We didn't know if they're alive
or not. You know, everything was
unknown. Yeah.
I don't know how baton took his
cell phone and we just ran barefoot.
Mayor says they ran out of the
apartment down the street, half naked,
holding the babies and the phone on the
way. They ran into their friend Gil,
who had four babies and another
couple who had two babies.
We are in this treat
and we are nine babies.
[inaudible]
they actually shot a video on [inaudible]
phone. You see tall only in shorts.
I don't have to go with this with a
look at a bunch of other couples holding
babies and they're all literally
standing on a pile of rubber
as they're standing there. A
guy with a badge, walks, walks
by y'all policeman. I love
you all from the a American.
Yes,
we are Israeli citizen.
We have nine, nine babies.
We need El please. We don't have
food for the babies. Okay, thank you.
Go from this chase very quickly
to go from here. Thank you.
So they took us in to the embassy,
the u s embassy or the Israeli embassy.
They went to the Israeli embassy and
the Israeli embassy sort of went into
emergency mode, gave us a some
blankets and hay put up, put out tents.
And shortly after the news cameras
arrived from Tal Tyler is a palace.
He's like in the media and
stuff because he's the,
he's the sign language translator.
And so he realized that he doesn't have
any way of communicating back home that
he's alive. So you, hi,
says a towels shoved his way in front
of one of the television cameras.
[inaudible] my name started signing
12 hours after the earthquake.
Maya says she got a call from her partner
back in Tel Aviv and she said they're
on the news now. Good mothering.
I can see tiles speaking,
sign language to his parents saying
everything is okay, they are alive.
Three babies are with them and they are
waiting to their rescue team to come and
take them.
But what the camera's also captured
was the scene that hadn't really been
grasped yet. Cause this whole thing
has been going on kind of quietly.
Now you have an international earthquake.
Everybody's watching the television and
in the middle of the story they're like
10 Israeli babies and gay people and
all this. It was more than that. Babies.
Yeah. How many were
there? 24 on babies. 2024
um
wow. Yes. Whoa. Because there
is another agency that also,
it's like all of a sudden you realize
there's this pipeline of babies. Yes,
I'm moving from Nepal to Israel. Yeah.
[inaudible] Maya says when the images of
those 24 babies splashed across Israeli
TV screens was like the first time
that this other Augustine was eh,
discussed in the Israeli media such
way. She says, a huge debate broke out.
One side of the argument was, okay,
we are using women and it's Eh,
it's unmoral. And from the
other hand there was like, okay,
in Israel for gay couples, they
don't have a lot of choices. I mean,
and everyone was asking, what do we do
with all these babies and the surrogates?
There was like a huge argument in the
Israeli media about the questions of there
are women that are waiting to give birth
and we need to bring them to Israel to,
to give birth here cause
the fathers are here.
So they would fly the women to Israel,
have the baby and then fly them back.
Yes, they was talking about it. Yeah.
They talked about it. But I don't know.
I think the [inaudible] they could
not do that because that just,
it feels like kidnapping a lady. Yeah.
And so what happened was that very quickly
Israel sent over a search and rescue
and medical aid delegation in all the
babies and their parents.
They were basically just all put on
a plane and sort of the process was
expedited and they just brought
everybody over to Israel.
[inaudible]
back in Israel, a parade of newborns.
It will celebrate together knowing the
medical stress they've been through.
I'm very much aware of that. Many
in Nepal are still going through it.
So what happened to the
surrogates? Any idea
they checked with the agency, what is
the situation with the surrogate mothers?
And the answer was that two of them
are becking in the already and the warn
there in the earthquake.
And what about all the surrogates who are
in the Pol but hadn't given birth yet?
Yeah, I mean about them.
There's a big question.
I mean no one knows there were
like a worried fathers in Israel.
It's terrifying. All my thoughts,
all my prayers are for the surrogate
mother and for the unborn child
telling him your made it back to Israel
with their babies. They were fine.
But there was still a lot of questions
and if I were one of you guys,
I would still be
wondering after all these,
both of these women gave you as
you point out, a remarkable gift.
Both of you believe that you hope rather
both of you hope that that gift was
well rewarded and it was life changing.
But both of you don't know at this point
you're just a little suspicious that
maybe it wasn't.
And don't you have this funny feeling
that you need to find out whether they got
paid what you thought you'd paid them?
Yes. Like,
this is why we're so glad that we made
the connection with you guys and we heard
that you can,
hey, hi. And then maybe, yeah, so
yeah,
we started a kind of a
whole new leg of the story.
Hello? Hello. Hi Molly. Can you
hear me? Yes, I can hear you. Woo.
I hear some other things
too. Oh, what'd you, yeah.
Actually it might just
be static on the line,
but it kind of sounded like the
ocean. I'd just switch up the fan.
Just give me a second.
A producer, Molly Webster was able
to track down a reporter in India,
Nilanjan a BOMAC and she asked her
if she could find those surrogates.
Okay, so you had given me a
name, right? Lotus, Lotus.
Lotus has got a prison that in Nepal.
I actually call that person in Nepal and
they did tell me in the location of the
clinic part, I spoke to the
doctor and she said that yes,
I will put you in touch
with one of the surrogates.
And the next morning they were supposed
to touch base again, but then you know,
she just totally went in, communicated.
That's been the same day I opened my
mail and there was a mail from Israel.
You know them asking me like, just
like to stop the search for some time.
[inaudible] so
near them as far as we understand what
happened was that the doctor contacted
Lotus, Lotus contacted Talan Amir
saying call off the reporters,
you're putting these
women's lives in danger.
If someone in their village
sees a reporter hanging,
they'll know those women were surrogates.
That's not something these circuits
want people to know. Stop. Here's a,
here's my understanding and you
guys correct me if I'm wrong,
is say we had asked someone to look for
them and that person got kind of close
and then word got back to the agency and
that's created some pressure for us to
change and you know that's really what
we're sort of staring at right now is how
to respond.
We heard that there is a real threat on
their alive because of the culture of
the society that they live in. One of
them was Muslim. I don't know if a, if,
if the Muslim society is going to accept
the fact that she carried the pregnancy
to a gay couple and two
squarely and to Israelis.
Yeah. So that's a very, very weird,
very delicate situation. Yeah. Firstly,
we don't want anything that may hurt, Eh,
the surrogate. Well, I mean,
we want to tell this story.
We definitely don't
want anyone to get hurt,
but I do feel like we have an ethical
obligation to hear from the women who do
this, if not the specific
women in this case,
than people who represent their
experience to whatever degree it can be
represented, it would be,
it would feel wrong for that to be a
voice that we don't hear. I don't know.
It's like, Eh,
it's for us, it's
a, yeah.
We don't want that.
Anybody will contact our surrogate and
if it says that it's not going to be a
without the story, so let's be it
because it's not worth it for us. Okay.
Understood. Understood. We won't make any
further attempts to contact those two,
those two, uh, women. Yeah.
Yeah. Just so we're all clear.
I think what I'd like to do is to
continue to pursue people who have been in
similar situations but are not in any way
connected to those two women or do you
guys,
yeah. Okay. I mean
again, we need to wear only make sure that
eh,
nobody's going to be hurt.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
Okay.
That's where we left things
with telling Amir and then, uh,
and then the story changed a lot.
It's coming up.
Hi Radiolab. This is Sally
calling from Melbourne Australia.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
from WM YC studios comes the untold
story of one of the most aspirational
and delusional teams in sports history.
We knew that we can beat
anybody in the world.
I'm doing everything I should be
doing and it's still not working.
So what do you guys, you guys can
play about it. You guys are the
ones that fricking caused this whole
American fiasco.
One team's insane journey to
the 1998 World Cup hosted by me.
Roger Bennett had men in Blazers
available wherever you get your podcasts,
a bad world cuff is better than
their workup. You Bet your ass.
Okay. I'm Jen Abu Rod. I'm Robert
Krulwich and Molly Webster.
This is radio lab and we will return
now to our collaboration with Israel.
Story producer is Maya
Kosovar and you. Hi, my tau a,
the story of telomere and their three
babies. Now, that's how it started for us.
It was a story of two guys
trying to have some kids,
but around the point of the earthquake,
uh, the story really shifted for us.
I mean, as it did for
the entire world really,
because we've been concentrating
the tale so far on the father's,
but with 24 some odd babies.
That's an awful lot of women
who had to carry those babies.
So what could they be thinking?
What is the story about them?
How are they feeling about
this transaction? Uh, how
much are they getting it?
Will it actually change their life?
These are some of the questions we had.
We gave those questions to Molly and
she sort of ran with it. Yeah. Yeah.
So in the months after the
earthquake, I guess you could say the,
like the political situation in Nepal
changed how everyone started looking
at surrogacy changed once everyone saw
these pictures of all these babies
outside the Israeli embassy being put on
airplanes and sent back to Israel, it
just cracked open this huge debate,
not just back in Israel,
but in Nepal and India.
Even internationally basically you
had groups coming out and saying like,
you know,
the feminists were saying
this is exploitation and
we're just using these women
for their wombs.
And there are op ed articles about should
we be shifting women across borders?
Is this the way you want to do surrogacy?
And then sort of the next
thing that happens, uh,
like three weeks after
we talked to talent Amir,
is that Nepal actually decided
to ban surrogacy completely,
completely for both straits, for both
same sex couples, foreign couples,
local couples, and for, for
Nepali, women couldn't do it.
An Indian woman couldn't come into their
borders and do it. No more surrogacy,
no more loopholes. No more
surrogacy, normal loopholes.
But then the confusion was
that they banned surrogacy,
but there was still a pregnant
surrogates on the ground.
And so they sort of existed
in this gray zone. Um,
and in the midst of that was when we
went out to try and find surrogates
in Nepal. All the surrogates are kept
in what are called shelter houses,
which are just like houses that, um,
agencies rent out that have a lot of
pregnant women. We still have these, yes,
they still have the houses,
like the rumors are that they move the
houses further away from the city center,
like attract less attention.
And so we found a Nepali reporter DJ
and I am a freelance journalist based in
Kathmandu to go try and get into
one of these shelter houses. So
the shelter house is actually quite
far from the main city centers. Almost
half an hour, 40 minutes drive
from Kathmandu. It's on a,
on a hilltop because these
are the outskirts of Katmandu
where new settlements
have just started. Uh,
so it was actually a school building,
which they turned into a shelter because
I think the school had left after the
earthquake.
The moment I reached the first floor,
I was so surprised. It was very noisy.
A lot of children playing around and
turns out a lot of women bringing their
young children if they're too young
to be left alone. Really? Yeah.
And how many women were there? They were
around I think 20 or 22 women there.
20 or 22 women on the first
floor of this building. Yeah.
This shelter house was run by
another Israeli agency, so not Lotus,
but a different one. And uh,
we're guessing that most of the women
were carrying babies for Israeli couples
and at least the women I saw who outside
the room or who had the doors open.
They seem to be around 30 to early
forties. Really? Yeah. I mean,
the first time I saw, I saw the first
woman I talked to kidney's Algeo in May.
She was wearing like a mustard
color. Sadie. She had some bangles.
All the women had some
bangles in their hands and
man [inaudible] she said
she was 36 years old.
[inaudible] from Kolkata.
[inaudible] she has two girls.
[inaudible] asked, how old are your girls?
And she said eight and 12 though
is how'd they do that? The N***A
[inaudible] number cutie asked like, why
are you doing this? And the woman said,
[inaudible] Oh, I'm doing it
for them. It's because you know,
we have a lot of financial problem.
My husband is a rickshaw driver and
we don't make enough and got him
[inaudible] she worked as a maid in Delhi
and ultimately she said she had no other
way to raise money for her daughters to
get married because
[inaudible] in Hindu weddings,
the bride's family pays off the
groom in the form of a dowry.
And the plan was to use the money from
surrogacy for the down room diets out of
mind. She'd been in
Katmandu for three months.
So she was in her first trimester
of a named and when per asked her
scaly [inaudible] Scowl Guy [inaudible]
does she know who the baby is for
[inaudible] she said no, the
settleable but she knows it's not hers.
Yeah, but that's what's top.
And actually all the women that
per QT talked to were very,
very clear about this. She's
at a middle one, not amendment.
This is a job we will eliminate
who I with the may have a Tiko.
The second woman I talked to, 30
years old, also a made in Delhi,
also two daughters. She
looked all dressed up.
She was already too as if she was about
to leave somewhere. And then I
realized, okay, her husband is here.
She had just given birth and she put
the job sentiment pretty plainly.
[inaudible] so she said, and I'm
translating here, may it by selling
[inaudible] I will give gladly, I will
give the baby from my wound. Yeah, but
[inaudible] if I will think this
is my baby, then how will it work?
I have two children. I
cannot take this child home.
[inaudible] I will have to give.
I have no sadness, no problem.
Anytime for QT asked these
women, are you conflicted?
Will you have trouble giving the baby
up? She always got the same answer.
Name Nay, nay, nay. Oh,
they always say that we would
happily give away the child and
[inaudible] if the baby comes out
right now I'll just give a trailer.
Did you get a sense that these women
didn't want it known that they were doing
this? Um,
I mean some of them did and some of
them didn't because some women were like
[inaudible]. They said like, now that
I'm here, my neighbors, my family,
everyone knows. Oh. And then
when recruitee asked her
[inaudible] do they have an opinion? Is
it right or wrong? She answered no, no.
[inaudible] I'm here for the money.
So I would not listen to any opinions.
If it was wrong, I would not come here.
But some of them were like [inaudible]
why would I tell anyone? You know,
there was one particular woman
[inaudible] 32 years old,
[inaudible] nail Polish on and
she had laid his pink lipstick on
[inaudible] she said, keep on my village,
simply do not believe these things.
We go nanny [inaudible]
and anyone's Oneida.
That one can have children by
getting injected or taking medicine.
[inaudible] they won't believe this.
She kind of do battles with how some
of the people in our village had done
something similar when
they bred cows or fishes.
[inaudible] you said like maybe they'll
understand but my family would not
understand name. She
says who'd want to go?
I have told lies to them.
[inaudible]
so how much in the end do they make?
I asked him [inaudible] how
much money do you get here?
I talked to four women and
the figure was the same.
Try to think
[inaudible]
Saturday the 3.5 lacks.
What does that mean in dollars?
So if you do the conversion, um,
today it's a 5,000, 300 US dollars.
And the way it works is that they get
paid a small amount of money every month
that they're pregnant.
And then at the end they get a lump sum
for Cudi says that for these women at
the end of the pregnancy, that lump sum,
it is like let's say around two or $3,000,
which is the amount that talent
Amir heard outside the embassy.
The total sum that they have
when they go back home is quite,
you know, it's not a lot. So five ish
thousand dollars is what you're hearing.
Yeah. Wow.
That's a difference to sort of see if
this was a number that was just coming out
of that shelter house or if it was
something that was like the going rate,
I guess. Uh, we talked to six
surrogates who are in India,
that same rate,
around $5,000 kept coming up and we did
hear a range from one surrogate. Um,
and this was about a friend of hers.
Uh, we heard as low as a thousand.
It's a surrogate getting only a
thousand dollars for a pregnancy. Yeah.
Yeah.
Hello? Hello.
This is Jerusalem calling
New York. Answering.
Ultimately we took this information
back to Tom and mere because this was
originally their question. So let's
talk about the money part now.
All right, so the last
time we talked to you,
you thought you were paying
your surrogates $12,000 yes,
around ish.
We've been off reporting and it seems
like the number that's coming up most
consistently for what surrogates are
reporting as their rate is 5,300 US
dollars.
What?
Yeah, I don't if it's fast. Too much.
Whoa, whoa.
It's too low. It's too low.
Really? Yeah. I want to cry.
We explained to them that if you
actually look at the contract,
the line that looks like it's to payment
straight to the surrogate doesn't
actually say this is
painted for the surrogate.
It says this is payment to
surrogacy services and it's
sort of like once you add
in that second word, it opens
the door to all kinds of things.
She's getting less
then the half.
It's very, it's like we feel like suckers.
It's a cool get the money.
So who got the money?
The question. It hung in the
air for a few weeks until
I have a around seven minutes before I
go into something that I did see my car
now
I was finally able to talk to Don and
Muck Dossey who is the head of Lotus,
which is the agency that
talent Amir used in Nepal.
She had just in the
morning I talked to her,
she had just flown in from Nepal to Israel
and I caught her in a car on her way
back to the airport and she was going
to fly off to Australia and I asked her
how much do the surrogates
actually get paid.
I can tell you truly that I worked in
Indiana college since 2010 and I cannot
tell you exactly how much the Jerry
eight holding your hand at the end of the
procedure because we don't transfer
the funds to the surrogate herself.
She's saying she has no idea and the
she has no idea is because she said this
and other agencies I spoke to said
this is that when you're working on the
ground in foreign countries
under the umbrella of surrogacy,
you are dealing with a lot of middlemen
and the middlemen have middlemen and
there are sub middle men.
The people who find the women in
India who get all the paperwork done,
who get them to the border,
who get them over the border,
who then bring them to some Paul,
someone meets them in Katmandu gets
them to the shelter house and all those
people may need to get paid.
I truly can't tell you that. I
truly don't know. After the agents,
you know how much the surrogates,
they have three to hands.
We don't come and ask the agent exactly
how much goes for her compensation.
Exactly how much goes for her and
nowadays we don't go into that.
I can tell you that.
Well, I guess I was thinking about,
I would feel conflicted as the
head of an agency to be like,
I think the money's going to some
people, but I just don't know.
Like I think that would niggle at me.
Yeah, well that's a good thing
that you're doing what you do.
You and I'm dealing with that.
Yes.
And you know, you can look
the whole world and say, okay,
I'm going to make it a brighter,
I cannot deal with all
the problems in the world.
We are trying to give
him as much as possible.
We paid the money for
this woman gets life and,
and now we understand it's
not exactly like that.
It's not right.
I mean that's the real, I think
the deep question here underneath,
after everything is over is when,
when we do a generous thing,
like we give people families who
couldn't have families before,
but that becomes a business.
Is there something about the business of
making a family that is always going to
be a little troubling and there are no
perfect ways to do this or is there a way
to pull this off in
some, I just don't know.
I mean like
I still have three more embryos that
they're in the freezer in Japan.
I don't know if the next time I would
not do the process may be in the state.
The U S is like an entirely
different surrogacy scene,
which we're just not going to get into
here. But the interesting thing that, uh,
that uh, Donna said and and,
and ahead of another agency was that they
think that in the next like five to 10
years,
the US will be one of the only countries
where surrogacy is still happening.
Right?
These things are closing down. Most
of the things are closing down.
So obviously Nepal has a band, Thailand,
it looks like a in a few days after this
piece comes out that India may ban it
for foreigners, Cambodia, there's
rumors that they're about to ban it.
And even in Canada, there are talks of
new restrictions on surrogacy and this,
these are bands like not just for same
sex couples, but uh, federal couples,
single people, everybody.
Oh. And the main reason
all of these bands and restrictions as,
as worries about, uh, exploiting women.
Yeah. I feel weird about that
a little bit though because,
cause if your ex, if
you're trying to, if you,
as we heard these women are making a
business decision whether or not we agree
with it as an entirely separate thing,
it seems they seem like
they're making a decision,
then we're going to take it away in order
to protect them. Feels, I don't know.
It's funny because it times, it also
feels it, you just think like, okay,
these women can decide how they're
going to use their own bodies. Right?
It's a little bit like a little black,
the abortion debate in a way. Totally.
Yes. But by the same token, it is,
it's not wrong for a society to say, Hey,
there are certain things
we just won't allow.
We won't give you that choice because we,
we find that the choice
itself is, um, is wrong.
[inaudible] I mean, it's fair,
but like one of the arguments
against banning it is that,
is that there's still a demand for
surrogacy and that that's not going to go
away. And so it just pushes
this system underground. And so,
uh, and, and then that way it's a
lot, you know, shady or, yeah. Um,
but the other thing was,
is that then Prakruti actually went
and talked to the women about like,
[inaudible] what this job does
for them up gazebos. I go to much,
I think you owe me like, okay, so
it's not the crazy amount of money.
We thought it might've been. It's
$5,000. Like what does that do for you?
[inaudible] that Asuka one woman
said, you know, when I get this money,
I'm willing to go back home
and start something when my
[inaudible] start a small shop. Do
you know my own little enterprise?
[inaudible] the other women,
all of them wanted to use
this money to build a house.
[inaudible] can you buy a plot of
land in New Delhi for five grand?
You definitely could not get a plot
of land in New Delhi for five grand.
But what these women do is they take
the money and they go back to their
original village and they use it
there to buy a small plot of land.
And that's totally doable and
it's actually no small feat.
Having that ownership of land is so
important in our societies in South Asia,
once you owned land in South
Asia, it raises your, um,
like socioeconomic status.
It's something that's passed
down through generations.
So you're like creating
something for your family.
And if you're one of the women
that may be already have land,
the thing you can do with that
$5,000 is build a house on it.
It's a very small like mud house or you
know, keep in mind like these women,
their day jobs are all made right?
And so they make less than
a hundred dollars a month.
They said had it not
been for this, I mean,
they would have never probably never
owned this much money at at a single
chance, but more than that,
like boom, guess what?
You're gonna cost when you go into
this, or at least when I went into this,
the thing that I expected to see
was like, okay, these are poor,
desperate women that are being
forced into this. Like right.
They'd been dragged across the border.
I think the thing that I was surprised
to see when I looked at the transcript
was that I'm cutting,
even though these women don't have a
lot of options and yes, they are poor,
they had chosen to do this out of
the limited options that they had.
They looked at them all
and they thought like,
this is the thing that I'm
going to do to get what I want.
It felt like these women
were making a choice.
I asked him [inaudible] what if you
were given a challenge to go abroad,
let's say Dubai or Qatar, because a lot
of women from India and [inaudible],
one of them said that, you know,
[inaudible] like why would I do that?
That would be very far away. She
says that here the kids can come,
their husbands can visit.
Oh, they're fed. Well
[inaudible] the surrogates get good
medical care that taken care of during the
whole nine months and,
and for this whole nine months they're
sending money back home and back home.
There's one less mouth to
feed. I think it'll be, I mean,
the way we passed judgment, you
know, you just pity on these women,
but I think they've, they are
very aware of what they're doing.
They might be exploited to
some level like you said,
but it seemed like the women in some ways,
they are in charge of deciding how they
want their life to be and we don't have
to look at them with, um, with PT.
No. [inaudible] the last woman
that Perkuto he spoke to,
she was a 32 year old
woman from Darjeeling.
She spoken to Polly and she told
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] I came here in March.
My embryo transfer was done once,
but I don't know if it was due to
the earthquake or something else,
but it didn't get heartbeat
and it got washed.
She said that she lost the fetus in
two months and he tried it twice on her
[inaudible]
per QT. How did you feel
when the child got washed?
Surrogate one nugget. I felt bad.
Oh Kayla, not I did what to say op? No.
Afnan I have noticed that Lachsa
it felt like it was my own.
Okay.
Buckle Tyna I'm a in queue and they
won't give money if it's unsuccessful.
They know they're not gum banana
[inaudible] well we, she, I, I'm like,
I didn't know if you miscarry you
don't get paid. Yes, yes, yes.
She says it's treated like a business.
You get paid for every month
you successfully carry and
if you do lose the baby,
depending on where it is in the pregnancy,
part of the money is refunded
to the intended parents.
[inaudible] surrogates.
Most of my friends had successful
stories to share back in Delhi.
Some of my friends made a house with the
money. Some bought land. I felt good.
[inaudible] [inaudible] she basically
says she wishes she had done this earlier
because now with the band she was
being sent back to her village.
She was still weeping on little of what
could have been if she was, you know,
if the eggs were healthy enough,
if it held those old right one
[inaudible] [inaudible] the money for
Kuti will you come again if this opens
back up and try again?
Repeat the own ones up
a 10 oh to surrogate.
Yes. I will come.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
producer Molly Webster.
there's something on your face that
says we're not quite done here.
What do you you want to wait?
We're done. We're done. No, no.
It was say which say what's on
your mind. Wow. I'm thinking.
I'm thinking about all the different
ways we've thought about the story along
the way of making it. I mean
you can read it as like,
this is a story about the
business of family making,
the outsourcing of babies. You can
hear it as a story about exploitation.
All these different things are
happening in the story, but yeah,
but it occurs to me that this is also a
story about the inventiveness of people
in some way, way you mean?
What do you mean by that?
I guess what I mean is like
the way that culture is,
we'll cross fertilize in these really
unexpected, like, okay, like this is,
these are two,
these are two sets of needs that are sort
of reaching out and finding each other
half a world away.
And there's a kind of symbiotic benefit
even while it's troubling and maybe
unfair, it's still kinda there and like,
so I feel like we could talk about
the story in any number of ways,
but I also feel like one of the things
that happened here is this is a story
about dreams and about aspiring
to have a better life. And how,
in this case,
those aspirations meet in this
really uncomfortable transaction.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah, let's thank people I said we
should do next. Let's thank them. Yeah.
So many people. Okay. Okay. Well
first we should, uh, we should,
I began thinking, uh, posse it
Israel story in Maya COSERV air.
We have just, we went in deep
with those guys for the story.
Check them out. It's really cool stuff.
At prx.org in Israel story.org what was
the one you were just telling us about?
Oh I love this one.
There's a story that they did last season
in which they went to every town in
Israel that has a Hertzel street.
Hurtles was like the George
Washington of Israel.
So they all have hurtful streets.
They'd knocked on 48 cause
Israel was found in 48.
They go knock knock who's there and
they opened the door in the interview,
whoever's on the other side of the
door. It's just a wonderful, cool idea.
And they get to meet a
crazy quilt of Israelis.
Well huge thanks to these road story
team and to Barry Finkle and to our
reporters in India Nilanjan at BOMAC
and in Nepal recruiting Rye and the
international reporting project for
connecting us with porters and translators
in different countries.
We talked to a lot of agencies
for the story surrogacy agencies.
Special thanks to and
Mamet and Dr Nine Up Patel.
Two our translators tell him Wasserman
Karthik Ravindra turn away Franz and out
of car, which is a Nepali community
organization out of Richard Queens.
And thanks to Ivan Zimmerman and for
music special thanks to Nos Jeeva,
enter the Balkan beat box. We
had production help for this.
A story from Andy Mills and this piece
was produced and reported by Molly
Webster. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm
Robert Krulwich. I'm Molly Webster.
Thanks for listening. Oh, one last
note. We should tell you that, uh,
telomere did meet their
surrogates very briefly one time.
And uh, it's kind of a cool moment.
We couldn't figure out where
to put it in this story,
but we have that scene on our
website@radiolab.org and it's worthless.